so you just flew in from New York how
are you feeling right now I'm having so
much fun in New York and it's just I
love comic-con and I'm happy I get to be
here what are you looking forward to
most whenever you come down to come back
you've been doing this for a while now
so like what do you look forward to when
you're coming down here
it's just meeting a lot of really
wonderful people and it's like a
community of people that all love the
same things and are true fans and that
energy is so fun to be around
yeah your true fans have a lot to look
forward to coming up this year and
Supergirl what can you tell us about the
big bat woman crossover I can't tell you
anything and I wish I could because I
don't know much I am pretty sure knowing
the way the crossovers have been going
crisis on Earth X was so much fun to
film so I have no doubt this year will
be awesome
you get excited every time that does not
work you need to expand this universe
and get more more characters into it
yeah I think it's so cool that you know
DC has this huge cache of characters why
not try to integrate all of them
together when you can have see something
come to life from the page to screen
like that that's so exciting we have Nia
now coming in and the first transgender
character is now the perfect time for
that now I think it's the perfect time
to show inclusivity and and love and
acceptance and understanding and
you know tell people's stories that
aren't always told yeah they're coming
up to the end of your runs Carole King
on Broadway is it bittersweet yeah of
course it is I love being on stage and
it has been such a joy for me and really
soul fulfilling but I'm really itching
to get back to my family in Vancouver
yeah do do you find that your experience
in Broadway is going to be affecting how
you do your work moving forward
absolutely I think not just with what I
was reminded of and being on stage again
what that entails but also Carole King's
spirit will never leave me she is an
incredible force yeah is there a bit of
Carole King in Supergirl I think there's
a bit of Supergirl in Carol Kaye yeah
she is a super girl yeah he's a
real-life superhero and telling her
story has been really inspiring awesome
hey thanks for your time enjoy the con